[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Полісся
Селезівка]
Дід, прадід і прапрадід займались бортями.
Довбали ці вулики, колодки
і розвішували по лісу.
Як кажуть, виходить, що в нас дикі бджоли.
Це ж не рамкові — дикі.
І вони самі поселяються в борть,
вощину відтягують та борються з різними негодами
[Зінькевич Павло
Мешканець Селезівки]
Борті — це щось таке,
схоже на живий організм.
У нього є п'ятка, голова,
чубчик, оцей отвір, сніп.
Це йшло від діда-прадіда.
У нас траплялись деякі борті,
відрубані сокирою.
[Володимир Андрощович
Мешканець Селезівки]
Борті можуть дуже довгий час існувати.
Переважно це старі дуби,
але всередині у них пусто.
Оцих бджіл називають «дрібні волохаті слєпотні».
Вони можуть селитися навіть у трухлявих пеньках.
Є два підвиди місцевих бортевих бджіл.
Одна наша, яка селилася
далеко від заплав річок —
сіра волохата, або слєпотні,
як місцеві називають.
А інші бджоли великі жовті, вони якраз у заплаві.
Це пов'язано з невеличким розміром квіточок.
І навіть анатомічно відрізняються ці бджоли.
Для великих квіток потрібен довгий хоботок,
для менших — дрібненький.
Я завжди все, що квітне, —
збираю в букет. Нарвав отак.
Беру теж корені з сосни.
[Сергій Жила
Мешканець Селезівки]
Це кришиться, ломиться.
Отак: раз-раз-раз.
Це сухе. І все. І туди поклав.
Всередину вулика.
Запах йде, який вбиває там усіляку заразу,
виганяє з вуликів.
То усі так роблять.
Постійно.
Бризкають, цукерки
розводять [водою], дюшес.
І з пляшки бризкають.
На запах теж хороший бджоли йдуть.
У нас дід дуже займався.
Батько трошки менше.
У нас було оце лізиво, щоб лізти на сосну,
потім спускатись, сідати.
Це лізиво теж робили діди наші.
Не було ж раніше цих мотузок, батогів.
А робили його із лосячої шкіри.
Нумо в'яжи сокиру й димар.
Так, в'яжи-в'яжи.
Вдома можна все самому робити,
а тут вже треба помічника, щоб все в'язав.
Він в'яже тобі.
А як прив'язався,
то вже дві руки вільні.
Уже не треба триматись ні за що.
Я вже можу працювати тут спокійно.
Цей мед зі всяких-різних квітів.
Я його не можу дістати,
тільки беру восени і навесні те,
що залишається.
Ціле літо вони збирають геть усе, одну вощину
[листки з бджолиного воску].
— А в «рамочному» як?
— В «рамочному» цвіло собі щось там: гречка...
— ...акація чи...
— Його викачали.
... чи ріпак.
Його викачали і все.
А тут геть усе разом.
Мій батько — Баб'як Петро Васильович
народився 1933 року.
Похвалюся.
Хоч мій чоловік кричить: «Вовки!», але похвалюся.
[сміється]
Наше прізвище колись було Мазепа.
[Тетяна Старинська
Мешканка Князівки]
Але як Петро І прийшов
і наклав анафему [заборону] на Мазепу,
предки наші трохи злякалися
і змінили прізвище.
З «Мазепа» на «Баб'як». Таке рідкісне прізвище.
Займалися бджільництвом і дід, і прадід.
Весь рід Баб'яків. Геть усі.
Таке родове повір'я є:
якщо загинуть бджоли, то загинуть і люди, людство.
То вони самі займалися і роздавали людям бджіл.
І мед роздавали просто так.
Було таке обов'язкове правило,
коли глядиш за бджолами.
«Глядиш» означає «збираєш мед».
Потрібно було, як коли хтось іде,
то треба шматочок меду дати.
Просто так.
Я стала сиротою в 8 років.
Але завжди займалася бджолами. Завжди.
І я лазила, робила вулики із батьком ось тут.
Де низько, то я робила сама.
А де високо на деревах, то просила родичів,
щоб допомогли.
♪ ... то пошиє собі радюгу. ♪
♪ Як виведе третю, ♪
♪ як виведе третю, ♪
♪ то пошиє шубу Шабетю. ♪
♪ Як останутса конци, ♪
♪ як останутса конци, ♪
♪ то пошиє хлопцам штанци. ♪
Одружився я з Танею,
а її батько пасікою займався.
[Юрій Старинський
Мешканець Князівки]
Десь я став коло нього,
і почав він показувати що і до чого.
Одразу не тягнуло до них.
Не знав тієї системи.
А потім втягуєшся, втягуєшся,
і вже тягне до них.
Просто цікаво.
Я навіть не думав, що я цим займатимуся.
Такої думки навіть не було.
Але якось так втягнувся.
Сподобалось. І став займатися.
У нас в селі брат мого тестя займався.
Двоюрідний брат тестя займався бортнями.
Вони вже стали старі.
Брат тестя помер вже.
Племінники не хочуть цим займатися.
Двоюрідний брат тестя теж уже старий.
Йому не можна по деревах лазити.
Він ще вдома тримає рамочні.
І кілька колод їхніх є, бортнів.
[собака гавкає]
А так, з нашого села, тільки я в лісі маю.
Займаюся ними.
[собака гавкає]
І думаю, займатимуся скільки зможу.
Є легенда про бджіл.
Колись, у сиву давнину,
в цій місцевості не стало бджіл.
Що ж робити? Немає бджіл!
Ми загинемо. Людство загине.
А колись були старі діди.
З бородами такими сивими, майже білими.
І от вони завезли туди  вулик.
З медом, з цімором. З воском, з прополісом.
І вони його запалили, цей вулик.
І він горить, клекоче,
запах іде такий приємний на цілу округу.
Ну і вже друга половина дня, а бджіл немає.
Вечір, вже сонце сідає. А нема бджіл.
Ну вже кажуть діди:
«Не буде вже бджіл».
Аж тут кажуть: «Є! є!»
Одна близько, як от ми стоїмо,
продзижчала бджола.
Бо вона до вулика летить і чує цей запах.
І кажуть: «Будуть бджоли!»
І через деякий час прилетів
величезний-величезний рій.
Ну, у нас тут в рою є матка. І бджоли.
Робочі і трутні там є.
А той рій прилетів з королевою.
Вона набагато більша за матку.
Казав мій батько: «Отака, як палець».
Показував на собі.
Ну, я не знаю, чи бачив, але йому так діди казали.
І відтоді вони кожен рій поділили між собою.
І до цього часу в нас бджоли є.
Отака легенда.
Є рої, де бджоли спокійні.
Але є такі бджоли, до яких
без димаря краще не підходити.
А є шкідні. Такі кусючі.
— Мого батька за спину штук 300 кусало.
— Ось тут є таке чорненьке.
Отак рукою брала жала.
Отак просто згортала.
У нього температура підіймалась.
Мандраж такий був, але нічого.
Там в нього дірка була на майці,
та й вони його пожалили туди. Штук 300 вкусило.
А він каже:
«Візьми, Таню, та повиймай жала.
Бо воно ж отруйне».
Я отак просто взяла рукою і позгрібала-позгрібала.
Та я взяла і жала повитягала.
Бо не буду ж я кожне виймати.
Отака історія.
Так, без димара ніяк не обійтись.
Постійно з димарем. Постійно.
Ще, навіть, як рій виходить, ми кропимо його водою.
Усі 15 хвилин, як він сидить нагорі.
То ми покропили водою,
крила змочуються і їм треба махати крилами,
щоб вони висохли.
Тоді вони можуть летіти.
Українці ж, я вважаю, робочий,
працелюбний народ.
У нас як...
Ми нація, яку знищують,
знищують і ніяк не можуть знищити.
Працелюбні люди.
Господарі.
Немало, де я їздив, багато де був.
Таких працелюбних людей я не бачив.
У службі поїздив багато.
Вони най-най, українці.
І зайти в хату приємно.
Воно деколи  нерви заспокоює.
Деколи. Ну, в житті всяке буває.
Чи зле, чи розсерджуся,
просто підійду до бджіл і постою біля них.
Спостерігаєш за ними і все забуваєш.
Колись мені батько казав,
що десь в якомусь місці чи країні, не знаю...
Якийсь Хапун хапав людей щороку.
Тобто збиралося зібрання людей.
Люди сідали. Чи вони там молились,
чи що там робили...
Але кожного року в них забирали по людині.
Хтось, якась невидима сила забирала людину.
І вони не знали, шо то за причина.
Але палили вони, при тому, свічки з лою
[топлений жир рогатої худоби].
Ну і от якийсь такий настав час,
що не стало тих лойових свічок.
І вони кажуть: «А що ж робити?
Не стало лойових свічок».
«Є воскова. Спробуємо нею».
Коли вони запалили воскову свічку,
пішов такий приємний запах по тій кімнаті.
І вони сиділи-сиділи, чекали,
що хапун вхопить ту людину.
І, уявляєте, не вхопив.
Відтоді говорять, що бджола є Божа комаха.
Вона ніби від Бога.
Бо говориться, якщо прийшов якийсь злодій
і хоче меду, і вигнав бджіл.
Чи викурив, чи водою залив, чи чим...
То прирівнюється до смертної кари.
Так говорили.
А коли, бджола є Божа комаха,
і мед, і віск йде на похвалу Богу.
Той віск, та воскова свічка, що вони запалили,
ніби відігнав ту нечисту силу від них.
І перестали людей хапати.
Отака легенда.
♪ Вискочив зайчик на ячнище
[поле, на якому ріс ячмінь] та й скаче, ♪
♪ пропив батенько свою донечку та й плаче, ♪
♪ пропив батенько свою донечку та й плаче. ♪
♪ Не плач, не плач мой батеньку за мною, ♪
♪ я й не заберу твого добречка з собою, ♪
♪ я й не заберу твого добречка з собою. ♪
♪ Оно заберу скрині, перини й корову,
тобі кидаю хату, сінечки й комору. ♪
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажер
Олексій Собчук]
[Редакторка відео
Карина Пілюгіна]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Музика
Endless Melancholy, Sleeping Bear, DakhaBrakha]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]